corporate innovation is dead
and corporate innovation is going to
come from two places it's going to come
from startups and it's going to come
from scunt works
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitech
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this is going to be a very special
episode a one that i enjoyed so greatly
meet sahih weissfeld vice president and
intel but much more than that
taki is a seasoned executive serial
entrepreneur and intel vice president
and matt general manager of ignite
his career span of 25 years in tech
consumer and enterprise markets
president of asn accelerating startup
nations sahih was one of the founders of
the microsoft israel r d site and a
member of its management team for eight
years this was also head of microsoft
for startup and founder of the microsoft
accelerators his responsibilities span
across 110 countries and included
microsoft bispark a global startup
accelerator partnership with more than
200 accelerators in 47 countries
microsoft later stage accelerators in
seattle bangalore beijing shanghai
berlin london and tel aviv as well as
post acceleration programs and vc
engagement prior to microsoft for
startups sahih co-founded a few startups
including sequoia-backed mintigo
acquired by anaplan was vice president
of marketing and strategy at modu the
israeli personal communications startup
whose ip was sold to google
tahi held the position of senior
director of business management at
microsoft prior to his period at
microsoft he was the general manager of
america's incorporate vice president for
the mobile market at m systems which was
acquired by sandisk for 1.6 billion at
the end of 2006.
additionally sahih is among the 10 top
most influential israelis in tech
worldwide according to business insider
in 2014 and was also named one of the
top influencers on israeli tech by news
geek magazine in 2015.
[Music]
i'm not interested in talking about
one of the specific companies you've
co-founded and you've co-founded a bunch
of them that have got acquired and
backed by some of the top vcs in the
world we're also not going to talk about
a specific experience in either
microsoft or intel uh because we want to
touch on a bigger theme here which is
this idea of corporate reinvention and
innovation
and so i'm really excited to host you
here thank you for coming and and i want
to start talking by having you for a
second sit back and reflect on
sort of the
since like in the 1990s when you started
in tech
well
no
who are you
in the tech world are you an
entrepreneur are you an entrepreneur who
are who is safe sure so um so again
excited being here um
safety or zack waistball depends on the
side of the world you're at um
i've been
and i i i think of myself as an
entrepreneur first and i've been an
entrepreneur for the past 30 years so
um
eight years in the valley
uh the rest here in israel different
sizes of companies from bootstrapping to
raising 120 million dollars and selling
to google for close to nothing
uh but also being a corporate
interpreter
so mid 2018 i left microsoft for the
third time uh for whatever reason the
company accepts me accepted me back
every time
and and uh really tried to reinvent uh
microsoft in many ways and we're gonna
talk talk about that and now
running um
intel for startups here
um
it was it's fascinating journey right
being in the early
early um
internet days i was a ceo of a small
startup a small israeli
internet company in mid-90s
where
internet just started right we were the
second biggest inter internet portal of
the country company called netking we're
probably the first
we were the first digital agency so
we've built the websites for some of the
biggest companies here and i brought
doubleclick to israel for the first time
so that was really when
when when this whole phenomena started
and um
then throughout the year saw a lot of
these uh changes that that we went
through you know the web
that was web 1.0 then 2.0 then you know
we're going through definitely
blockchain and and um um you know
metaverse now etc so it's been it's been
a fun ride
i think what's what's um
what was fascinating also is to see not
just the startup world but how does
these large multinational corporations
are dealing with with the fact that
destruction
is happening on the outside is not just
happening on the inside i think that's
that was the fun part of my journey that
was a bit different a lot of my friend
that stayed a lot of my friends that
stayed running more and more startups
eventually became received
and supported startups um
that that was a kind of a shift i made a
certain point in my career
and so you're
you're making this shift and you're
understanding that
there's this whole other paradigm to the
world
of of incumbents
that have phenomenal people phenomenal
technologies
but they're perhaps a little bit
misunderstood perhaps both internally
and externally
with vast potential
that any startup would love to have and
something about this resource is being
underutilized
and and it sort of clicks for you what
what is sort of this thesis that you
start building for yourself
so
clearly
the one big difference between these
huge
behemoths these huge companies with
amazing talent super deep super strong
super smart um and and these small
startups they're also super smart and
and um you know they want to eat the
whole world what the difference is the
culture right there's a big
culture
differences between these two kind of
of um animals and
um
i told you earlier one of the quotes
as i was working at microsoft and trying
to do this work and and
one of the
one of my mentors at microsoft an
amazing guy
very small
uh chilo he was the head of um head of
office and bing he was an executive vice
president microsoft under palmer i heard
about those products yeah they're very
very small 40 billion business right and
she told me the time said zach you know
what corporate innovation is dead
and corporate innovation is going to
come from two places it's going to come
from startups
and it's going to come from scunt works
and i won't go too much into the punk
works you know phenomena uh but but
specifically on the startups i actually
took this as my
part of my main mission is to help
reinvent
some of these large amazing companies
through this journey with startups and
and um when walking through the or walk
through the journey at microsoft was
interesting i i
um
i came back to microsoft back in 2010
for the third time
and i was hired into microsoft israel
after i was part of the
founding team of the microsoft rd center
at the time and then later as i was
asked to come back and help with two
things help connect stuff microsoft to
startups and help drive acquisitions
but very quickly i figured the problem
was not local the problem was global
microsoft forgot how to speak and how to
engage with startups
and um
i met with satya nadella so our my team
reported to satya nadella he was the
head of her server and troll division
was before he was deceived
and they brought with me a blog post of
the guy you probably know paul graham so
paul graham was the founder of y
combinator
and
still on his private blog there's a blog
post that's titled microsoft is dead
and he said microsoft is dead
microsoft used to shed a big shadow on
the tech world haven't realized on the
shadow disappeared and the third thing
he said wow i don't invite them anymore
to my demo days
and i went to saturn and said satya
black over internet it says we're done
we're dead we're out of the picture
and asked his permission to reinvent the
way the company works with entrepreneurs
and built built this program a startup
accelerator program now
2010 2011 microsoft was the evil empire
no one wanted to work to do anything
with microsoft i have a good friend here
at vc in israel
that i told them
jenny i'm going to start this
accelerator for microsoft and he said do
you think he said one
not a single startup in his right mind
would want to join a microsoft
accelerator and the second thing he said
is
i'm not going to invest in any of the
companies that went through your program
because they're idiots
that's this was this was the way it
started right then and
uh
and i said okay as an entrepreneur i
said okay that's an opinion
he's entitled his own opinion i think
differently and i see things differently
and we started this program and we
didn't i mean you it wasn't just
differently you saw
he looked at the current state of
affairs he said wait i'm you know with a
few action items
it can be very different yes and and um
and then i i built this program it
started in tel aviv the television
bangalore beijing shanghai berlin london
paris seattle sydney
um
and we had some amazing companies go to
the program you know apps flyer and own
backup and spot and uh
some perry's just just got a huge uh
investment round last night denounced it
uh and fabric and really amazing set of
companies many unicorns that came out of
the program and
um it was a really really fun journey so
so we've done that we've shown
that we could help change the corporate
and change the engagement of these early
state startups with the corporate then
have both sides learn a lot in the
process startups leverage the amazing
resources and access these these
corporates have and the corporate
learning a new skill
learning you know how to be more nimble
learning the the world of these
disruptors which which was an amazing
amazing connection um so that was and
it's not startups obviously right
because i think today pretty
consecutively microsoft is ranked as if
not the top is one of the top places to
work for in israel i know about half of
my friends are working in in microsoft r
d this is it sounds like this is
something that 10 years ago
people would also say to you no way i
tried to hire entrepreneurs to run my
programs around the world and the first
thing most of them say is no way i'm not
going to work for microsoft
that was that was the way right that was
the thing and and you know
i was lucky enough to to do this under
satya i was lucky enough to have satya
take on the the ceo role and satya has
been amazing driving that change at
microsoft and and i had the opportunity
to be very close there with amazing
people through scott guthrie uh that
runs um
uh enterprise uh
sorry uh uh runs uh cloud and enterprise
and and
and many people organization that that
helped make it a reality but there was a
that was the microsoft journey which i
um i i
left mid 2018 because i haven't seen my
kids for too many years i i manage a
bench i manage a company an organization
called microsoft for startups 110
countries about 500 million dollars a
year spent on ecosystem development
and so i left i did i built four legos
in one year that i built all my life
before that
um and then
and then met
bob swann the ceo uh the former ceo of
intel so he wasn't a visit in israel uh
yaniv garthy this the um gm of intel and
israel and abner goran one of the senior
ctos here and architects a vp here
asked asked me to meet with bob and came
with the concept that we may change the
way intel works with with entrepreneurs
under the same challenge that these
companies have became
pretty separated from that energy of
these early stage startups now intel has
an amazing corporate venture fund
right working very well intel intel
capital is a great venture fund and and
it's been working for 30 years and
investing in israel and many other
places
but bob was concerned
that we're not learning enough in the
process of working with these startups
as a company
and and asked me to come on board as a
consultant basically helping build this
new program it's called ignite
under his part of the ceo
and um so this couple years ago
bob since left we have pat now as a ceo
an amazing ceo for intel which i believe
is going to reinvent that company this
amazing company and i report now to greg
lavender the cto of intel and um ignite
exists now in tel aviv it's in its
sixth batch uh we operate uh we have a
european program operating out of munich
and we're right now starting our boston
program and then london these are the
two next programs um the program got
awarded so so two and a half years ago
before we started
um as a consultant i went out and i
surveyed the market then i asked a
couple hundred startups which corporate
they want to engage with
and
uh we did both the ap the nominated
service we asked them
if you have every option in the world
and not even a single one said intel
right these were software them wow
and wow two and a half years later today
intel ignite has been no has been
awarded the number one startup
accelerator program in the country
uh it's ex we're getting about 250
applications per batch we're opening we
only accept 10.
and we already have
an example for a first batch company of
granulate
that uh came to us with four and a half
million dollars our first badge there
were five people
and then lately you entered an
acquisition
very very significant acquisition by uh
by intel and almost 30 percent of the
companies through the program actually
doing vocs today with intel uh and they
don't have to be
ship companies they don't have to build
asics
they could be enterprise sas
cyber security in a variety of areas um
they deal with they need to be deep in
technology
but we're interested to connect bridge
connect with all these disruptors across
the world
and um as as a testament for that
changing the company so a month ago we
got awarded by
intel ceo
what's the oscars of intel
or uh for the israelis on your crowd
what's known as bas bitton israel you
know the one thing that you get when you
save the country right that's big award
um so we got word that uh by intel ceo
and the intel um appreciation award uh
which is a very big deal here of of
actually making a big difference for the
company so
um again it's all about reinvention how
can we help reinvent these amazing
companies through the work we do with
startups
so i've i have to ask i mean you're it
sounds pretty con
consistently
you're going into these corporates and
within a very short amount of time
you're mad you're changing the narrative
globally
especially you know most predominantly
amongst those that that are relevant you
know these are the entrepreneurs these
are this is the ecosystem
is it i mean what what is it that you do
is it you know is it
un changing the narrative of the
organization is it changing internally
the organization changing the management
i mean
what's the magic sauce here so look
first of all like many things in like in
the investment world etc it's not
science it's art and i've been spending
the past 12 years or so
really
fine-tuning that machine to make that
impact
and
the first thing
that is
that makes the difference is what you
optimize for with these programs it's
really critical what you optimize for
and the number one mission what's on the
slide that's presented to the ceo of
intel was presented to satya at
microsoft is the number one mission of
the program is accelerating
groundbreaking startups
there's nothing about intel in that line
there's nothing about microsoft in that
line it's about how to take
the best possible startups
and how to make them as successful as
fast as we can um so it's all these
resources we we invest in making them
great now we take no equity we take no
pay
people ask me why don't you take equity
one of the tricks to get the best
companies possible is actually not to
take equity and then you can get the
granulates of the world and and and many
of these great companies now you say yes
but but you know but it doesn't make
sense it makes a lot of sense because
ending up as a as a large corporate with
hundreds of small equity
parts in in startups which most of them
are going to go anyway
doesn't really make sense and and we
could pay a small premium for the ones
we're really interested in in a later
stage so
the first thing is what do you optimize
scores so we're optimized first and
foremost about the startup if that
doesn't go that's not going to work and
we're not getting the best ones nothing
else is going to happen
then um
the other thing is
which again if you look at many of these
programs around the world many of these
corporate acceleration programs
what makes them successful or fail owns
out three things
one is how are they staffed
so
many programs are staffed by super smart
mba graduates that are really great
program managers
or staffed by sellers from the corporate
that's about to retire in the last few
years they let them run the corporate
accelerator or innovation program or
whatever both don't really work that
well and i'm sorry if i'm i'm pending
anything but but
what what really needs to to to happen
is the program has to be managed by an
entrepreneur
someone that
um
built a company hired buyer raised
funding from reputable investors
and bring their own network to work so
someone understand what does it mean to
get your term sheet pulled away in the
last minute
someone understands what does it mean
when your significant other at home sits
in front of you say you need to pick
it's either me of the startup
it had the
issue of almost not being able to pay
the team because the money just ran out
if you don't have that experience
personally it's very hard to build the
value that i believe needs to be built
in the program so staffing a managing
director that's been a zero entrepreneur
a cto which is a very senior technical
person
that understands and can help the
companies from product as well as
technology a deal full manager that's
super energetic
highly engaged in the in the community
of startups and universities and israeli
case it's the army
um
an op an ops manager that runs the
operations on day to day because there's
a space there's there's a program
and then someone on the business side
that
is a success manager someone that's that
does value creation so that's the team
right that's the pod
so this is the first thing is how you
staff the second how do you fund many of
these programs
are hobbies they are not business
i said ignite is not a hobby and
microsoft excel was not a hobby it was a
program that has to be fully funded
it's not supported by a bank that so
smep wants to come and do an event great
i don't need them to fund my program
um i don't want to be reliant reliant on
sponsors right the program has to be
fully funded by the corporate
so
first thing is staffing the second thing
is fully funded program and the third
thing
which is probably the most important one
is who is the sponsor in the
organization
best case ceo
satya was my
sati was my sponsor uh before he was the
ceo later on and then bob swan the
former ceo of intel was my sponsor um
and um or if it's not the ceo it's
someone that reports the ceo
so today it's greg lavender at intel
he's i i report to him and he is the
sponsor for unite in microsoft it was um
it was scott guthrie for his org so
super critical to have uh the
organization the program report the
right places because then you can make
an impact otherwise many of these
programs end up as marketing or or
community support or whatever and they
don't survive
too many years
right so sorry for the lying and answer
but i think these are the kind of things
that that make these programs successful
i think that what what what sticks with
me besides the i think each each of
these pieces on their own i think is
phenomenal because you're touching on
these decision making points that that
people make and and perhaps they're not
sure you know whether it's the right
decision to make and and there's
different considerations on all ends um
but but overall what really got to me
was this idea that it's it's 12 years of
art in the making
right i mean this is a process that
you've done again and again
understanding deeply understanding the
needs deeply understanding the
entrepreneurial mindset transitioning to
corporate mindset within corporate
mindset also
continuously reinventing yeah and and
having this global experience
the energy that you bring to the table i
can only imagine why these these
phenomenal leaders
are are taking some of their precious
time to to back these amazing
initiatives because i i can't think of
much stronger
bets than when i see when when a ceo or
cto of such a large organization comes
and says i want to buy this i'm buying
into you and i'm even i even want to
look at the slide which says the mission
that you're presenting that's a huge
idea and that's look we just came we had
an event in in
dallas uh
last week and pat the ceo of intel came
to spend time with with the 10 startups
we brought in
and to see pat come to come in and ask
questions one of uh oxi one of our
startups and asked them to tell me um
is it i don't understand is it passive
or is it dynamic protection you're doing
and asking another startup i don't
understand exactly the kind of customer
so elo maxina from element he came and
said i'm kind of struggling with what is
the exact customer
who is the person you're selling into at
the customer and that's again pat
intel ceo
really trying to understand the business
and technology of these little startups
gets highly energized and then follow up
on these meetings by sending other
people they things need to learn and
need to engage
and and you know how can we
we do something bigger together with
these tiny startups and that's i think
the beauty of it
you you get to these amazing leaders of
these big companies and they look at
these startups and they they don't say
look there's a tiny startup let's figure
out how we can help them say hey what
can we learn how can we co-create a
better future together
i don't care how small they are they're
super brilliant and they could be super
relevant for our success and i think
that's a
that's a huge difference right so yeah
so so so that that
again worked well in in these few
companies and a few more that i i work
with as well in
in my period between the two
i can't wait to continue following the
journey thank you so much for your time
and for your contribution to to startups
our ecosystem the global ecosystem
corporates uh it's really it's really
inspiring for me to to hear these these
stories and uh and uh i really
appreciate your time so thank you very
much i have the best
the best job in the world i get in one
end to help
rebuild or reinvent these huge amazing
companies
uh with the support of these great ceos
and leaders and on the other hand i get
to play with all these startups
constantly and get hundreds of amazing
amazing founders that i can help be
successful so best world
job in the world and by the way i get
paid for it so that's even better
[Music]